This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you listen to our show last year, you may have heard the voice of Elliot Kalin, who was my co-host for a series we did on the book, The Power Broker. And as far as I'm concerned, Elliot was the perfect co-host. He's smart, knowledgeable, easy to talk to, and he's also very, very funny. Because when he's not moonlighting at 99PI, Elliot is a professional comedy writer. And over the years, he has written comedy in just about every media. there is. He worked for over a decade at The Daily Show with John Stewart, where he eventually became the show's head writer. He did stand-up. He writes comic books. And currently, he is the co-host of the original Bad Movie podcast, The Flop House, and the showrunner for the forthcoming Netflix Ghostbusters animated series. We want to have Elliot back on the show because
This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you listen to our show last year, you may have heard the voice of Elliot Kalin, who was my co-host for a series we did on the book, The Power Broker. And as far as I'm concerned, Elliot was the perfect co-host. He's smart, knowledgeable, easy to talk to, and he's also very, very funny. Because when he's not moonlighting at 99PI, Elliot is a professional comedy writer. And over the years, he has written comedy in just about every media. there is. He worked for over a decade at The Daily Show with John Stewart, where he eventually became the show's head writer. He did stand-up. He writes comic books. And currently, he is the co-host of the original Bad Movie podcast, The Flop House, and the showrunner for the forthcoming Netflix Ghostbusters animated series. We want to have Elliot back on the show because|||这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你听过去年我们的节目，你可能听过埃利奥特·卡林的声音，他曾是我制作关于《权力经纪人》一书系列节目的联合主持人。就我而言，埃利奥特是完美的联合主持人。他聪明、博学、健谈，而且非常非常幽默。因为当他不在99PI兼职时，埃利奥特是一位专业的喜剧编剧。多年来，他几乎在所有媒体上都写过喜剧。他在《乔恩·斯图尔特每日秀》工作了十多年，最终成为了该节目的首席编剧。他表演过单口喜剧。他写过漫画书。目前，他是原汁原味的烂片播客《烂片屋》的联合主持人，也是即将上映的Netflix《捉鬼敢死队》动画系列的剧集主管。我们想让埃利奥特再次做客节目，因为
he has now written a book of his own, not so much about his career, but about his craft. He says, when you write jokes for a living, it takes a lot more than just having a good sense of humor. Instead, you have to have a system. The book is called joke farming, how to write comedy and other nonsense. And he's here to talk about it with us. Elliot Kalin, it is so nice to have you back. Thank you, Roman. It's great to be back. Thank you so much for having me on to promote a book that I may make some money off of. After we did so much to put some money in Robert Carroll's pockets, I appreciate my getting a shot at it. That's right. That's right. So let's get down to the basics, the very, very beginning. You know, what on earth made you think that you could write
he has now written a book of his own, not so much about his career, but about his craft. He says, when you write jokes for a living, it takes a lot more than just having a good sense of humor. Instead, you have to have a system. The book is called joke farming, how to write comedy and other nonsense. And he's here to talk about it with us. Elliot Kalin, it is so nice to have you back. Thank you, Roman. It's great to be back. Thank you so much for having me on to promote a book that I may make some money off of. After we did so much to put some money in Robert Carroll's pockets, I appreciate my getting a shot at it. That's right. That's right. So let's get down to the basics, the very, very beginning. You know, what on earth made you think that you could write|||他现在写了自己的书，与其说是关于他的职业生涯，不如说是关于他的手艺。他说，以写笑话为生，需要的远不止是好的幽默感。相反，你必须有一套系统。这本书叫《笑话耕作：如何创作喜剧及其他废话》。他今天来和我们聊聊这本书。埃利奥特·卡林，很高兴你能回来。谢谢你，罗曼。很高兴回来。非常感谢邀请我来宣传一本我可能会从中赚点钱的书。在我们为罗伯特·卡罗的口袋赚了那么多钱之后，我很感激自己也能有机会赚一把。没错。没错。那我们来谈谈基础的东西，最开始的东西。你知道，到底是什么让你觉得你可以
jokes for a living. The great thing about writing jokes for a living is that less that you need someone to tell you you can do it and more that no one can tell you not to do it. And it helped that I grew up also watching television in the early 1990s when there was still a lot of stand-up comedy on television in particular. Like you and I, I'm a little older than you, but there was this phase of like cable television where all of a sudden you saw somebody standing in from a brick wall You know, like, as part of television, you know. And now we live in a world where it feels like there's more comedy than not comedy. So now it seems quaint, but it felt like there was so much comedy around that this is something you could do.
jokes for a living. The great thing about writing jokes for a living is that less that you need someone to tell you you can do it and more that no one can tell you not to do it. And it helped that I grew up also watching television in the early 1990s when there was still a lot of stand-up comedy on television in particular. Like you and I, I'm a little older than you, but there was this phase of like cable television where all of a sudden you saw somebody standing in from a brick wall You know, like, as part of television, you know. And now we live in a world where it feels like there's more comedy than not comedy. So now it seems quaint, but it felt like there was so much comedy around that this is something you could do.|||以写笑话为生。以写笑话为生最棒的地方在于，比起你需要别人告诉你你能做到，更重要的是没有人能阻止你去做。而且这也得益于我在20世纪90年代初长大时也看电视，当时电视上特别是还有很多单口喜剧。就像你和我一样，我比你大一点，但当时有这样一个有线电视的阶段，你突然看到有人站在砖墙前，你知道的，就好像是电视的一部分。现在我们生活在一个感觉喜剧比非喜剧更多的世界里。所以现在这看起来有点古怪，但当时感觉周围有那么多的喜剧，以至于这成了你可以做的事情。
And so I very foolishly somehow managed to achieve the lucky breaks to succeed at doing it, which baffles me and my family to this very day. But what I'm curious about is, like, you got into this because the adults in your life told you you are a naturally funny person. You're a person that just makes people laugh. But that is not enough if you need to produce the Daily Show. You can't just be naturally funny. It is a job. And you cultivated this thing called joke farming as a way to produce all the jokes that you have to do for something like the Daily Show. Do you talk about joke farming and how you sort of developed it as a discipline?
And so I very foolishly somehow managed to achieve the lucky breaks to succeed at doing it, which baffles me and my family to this very day. But what I'm curious about is, like, you got into this because the adults in your life told you you are a naturally funny person. You're a person that just makes people laugh. But that is not enough if you need to produce the Daily Show. You can't just be naturally funny. It is a job. And you cultivated this thing called joke farming as a way to produce all the jokes that you have to do for something like the Daily Show. Do you talk about joke farming and how you sort of developed it as a discipline?|||所以我非常愚蠢地以某种方式抓住了幸运的突破口，成功地做到了这一点，这直到今天仍然让我和我的家人感到迷惑。但我好奇的是，你进入这一行是因为你生活中的成年人告诉你，你是一个天生幽默的人。你是一个能让人发笑的人。但如果你需要制作《每日秀》，这还远远不够。你不能只靠天生幽默。这是一份工作。你培养了一种叫做“笑话耕作”的东西，以此来产出像《每日秀》这样节目所需的全部笑话。你能聊聊“笑话耕作”以及你是如何将其发展成为一门学科的吗？
I feel like the difference between being a funny person and being a comedy professional is the ability to be funny not just spontaneously, not just. for whoever you're talking to, but to be funny on demand in a professional manner when it needs to be done. You can't wait for inspiration to strike. It has to be a reliable thing that you can go to when you need it
I feel like the difference between being a funny person and being a comedy professional is the ability to be funny not just spontaneously, not just. for whoever you're talking to, but to be funny on demand in a professional manner when it needs to be done. You can't wait for inspiration to strike. It has to be a reliable thing that you can go to when you need it|||我觉得幽默的人和喜剧专业人士之间的区别在于，能够不仅在即兴时幽默，不仅在对你交谈的任何人面前幽默，而是在需要的时候以专业的方式按需幽默。你不能等待灵感降临。它必须是一件可靠的事情，当我们需要时你可以随时调用它
and you can command it to a certain extent rather than letting it command you. And so when I was working at The Daily Show, I worked with a lot of writers, and I was like this too, where at first it was writing by gut. You're writing the thing that you think is funny in the moment and you spend a lot of time
and you can command it to a certain extent rather than letting it command you. And so when I was working at The Daily Show, I worked with a lot of writers, and I was like this too, where at first it was writing by gut. You're writing the thing that you think is funny in the moment and you spend a lot of time|||并且在某种程度上你可以掌控它，而不是让它掌控你。所以当我在《每日秀》工作时，我和许多编剧共事过，我也是这样，一开始是凭直觉写作。你写下你当下觉得有趣的事情，并且你会花很多时间
staring into space when something isn't coming to you. But when you're in an office And they're like, you know, it's, it's nine o'clock. And your script is due as 10.30. You can't do that. And so I knew I had to write a lot of jokes really fast. And I should define a joke is anything that is created in order to make someone laugh. That to me is a joke.
staring into space when something isn't coming to you. But when you're in an office And they're like, you know, it's, it's nine o'clock. And your script is due as 10.30. You can't do that. And so I knew I had to write a lot of jokes really fast. And I should define a joke is anything that is created in order to make someone laugh. That to me is a joke.|||当你想不出东西时呆呆地望着虚空。但当你在办公室里，而他们说，你知道的，现在是九点钟。你的剧本要在十点半交。你就不能那样做。所以我知道我必须非常快地写出大量的笑话。我应该把笑话定义为：任何为了让人发笑而创造的东西。对我来说，那就是笑话。
Got it. And if I'm not feeling funny that day, it doesn't matter. Like the show still needs it. And the show needs a lot of jokes. And it needs me to write them in, if I'm lucky, two hours, you know, often less than that. And so I started talking to myself about what is the unconscious process that my mind goes through when I am coming up with a joke off the top of my head. I need to verbalize it. I need to be able to articulate to myself so that I can then replicate it as a real deliberate process that can force
Got it. And if I'm not feeling funny that day, it doesn't matter. Like the show still needs it. And the show needs a lot of jokes. And it needs me to write them in, if I'm lucky, two hours, you know, often less than that. And so I started talking to myself about what is the unconscious process that my mind goes through when I am coming up with a joke off the top of my head. I need to verbalize it. I need to be able to articulate to myself so that I can then replicate it as a real deliberate process that can force|||明白了。如果我那天感觉不到幽默，也没关系。因为节目仍然需要它。而且节目需要大量的笑话。它需要我在幸运的话两个小时内写完，你知道的，通常比这还短。于是我开始对自己说，当我灵光一现想出一个笑话时，我的大脑经历了什么无意识的过程。我需要把它语言化。我需要能够向自己清晰地表达出来，以便我随后能把它复制为一个真正刻意的过程，从而强迫
myself to go through. And did you go through this exercise of figuring this out, verbalizing it at the time, or is this something that you did writing the book? Or is this, you know, like, did you? Oh, no, this is something I did at the time. This is, I was, I said to myself, I need to free myself from being changed to inspiration, basically, which is something I can't control. And so I want to have a process where you can take any subject and you can go through the steps of that process and then come out with a joke on the other end. And one of the things that I want to get across in the book is that you don't have to use my process, but it's good to have a process. And your process should mimic your way of thinking. It should fit your needs, your voice, how you most comfortably write. But whatever
myself to go through. And did you go through this exercise of figuring this out, verbalizing it at the time, or is this something that you did writing the book? Or is this, you know, like, did you? Oh, no, this is something I did at the time. This is, I was, I said to myself, I need to free myself from being changed to inspiration, basically, which is something I can't control. And so I want to have a process where you can take any subject and you can go through the steps of that process and then come out with a joke on the other end. And one of the things that I want to get across in the book is that you don't have to use my process, but it's good to have a process. And your process should mimic your way of thinking. It should fit your needs, your voice, how you most comfortably write. But whatever|||自己经历这个过程。你在当时就经历过这种弄清楚并将其语言化的练习，还是这是你在写书时才做的事情？或者这是，你知道的，就像，你做过吗？哦，不，这是我当时做的事情。这是，我当时对自己说，我基本上需要把自己从对灵感的枷锁中解放出来，那是无法控制的东西。所以我想要有一个流程，你可以拿任何主题，然后经历那个流程的步骤，最后在另一端产生一个笑话。我想在书中传达的事情之一是，你不一定非要用我的流程，但拥有一个流程是好的。你的流程应该模仿你的思维方式。它应该符合你的需求、你的声音、你最舒服的写作方式。但无论
whatever that process is, it should be something that you know the steps of so that at those times when you don't have inspiration, but you need to produce a joke, you can do it. Okay, so let's talk about some of that processing and how the Daily Show process morphed into your own process that you described. I mean, for copyright and patent purposes, this is my own original process. I'm sure there's influences, but let's not give them too much credit. No, the thing I should say also about the working the daily show, I don't want to it to sound like I'm like, I'm a genius who came up with all this stuff. You know, this was very much
whatever that process is, it should be something that you know the steps of so that at those times when you don't have inspiration, but you need to produce a joke, you can do it. Okay, so let's talk about some of that processing and how the Daily Show process morphed into your own process that you described. I mean, for copyright and patent purposes, this is my own original process. I'm sure there's influences, but let's not give them too much credit. No, the thing I should say also about the working the daily show, I don't want to it to sound like I'm like, I'm a genius who came up with all this stuff. You know, this was very much|||那个流程是什么，它都应该是一件你清楚其步骤的事情，以便在那些你没有灵感但又需要创作笑话的时候，你能够做到。好的，那我们来谈谈其中的一些加工过程，《每日秀》的流程是如何演变成你所描述的你自己的流程的。我的意思是，出于版权和专利的目的，这是我自己的原创流程。我确信有受到影响，但我们别给他们太多的功劳。不，关于在《每日秀》工作，我还应该说的是，我不想让听起来好像我是个想出所有这些东西的天才。你知道，这很大程度上是
me being taught and led by the people I was very lucky to be working with. So your day at the daily show starts. There's lots of news. Some of it is hard news to figure out how to make comedy about. Some of it may be super easy to make comedy about. Some of it's very easy. There was one time there was a stadium that got built somewhere and from above it looked like a vagina. And it was a very easy one to write jokes about. Yeah. And so could you take us through the joke farming process us with a joke from the Daily Show. Sure. So the first thing I would have to do is consider who is telling this joke.
me being taught and led by the people I was very lucky to be working with. So your day at the daily show starts. There's lots of news. Some of it is hard news to figure out how to make comedy about. Some of it may be super easy to make comedy about. Some of it's very easy. There was one time there was a stadium that got built somewhere and from above it looked like a vagina. And it was a very easy one to write jokes about. Yeah. And so could you take us through the joke farming process us with a joke from the Daily Show. Sure. So the first thing I would have to do is consider who is telling this joke.|||我被那些我有幸与之共事的人教导和引领。所以在《每日秀》的一天开始了。有很多新闻。其中一些是很难弄清楚如何将其做成喜剧的硬新闻。其中一些可能非常容易做成喜剧。有些非常简单。有一次，某个地方建造了一个体育场，从上面看它长得像个阴道。这是一个非常容易写笑话的素材。是的。那么你能用《每日秀》的一个笑话带我们走一遍“笑话耕作”的过程吗？当然。所以我要做的第一件事就是考虑谁在讲这个笑话。
Who is the joke teller whose voice is it? Which in the case of the Daily Show, when I was there, would have been John Stewart. He's the host of the show. He's going to say all the jokes. Then I would try to say to myself, what is the point of this joke? And by point, I mean, what is the message I'm trying to get across in this joke? What's the meaning of it? Not necessarily the funny thing about it.
Who is the joke teller whose voice is it? Which in the case of the Daily Show, when I was there, would have been John Stewart. He's the host of the show. He's general say all the jokes. Then I would try to say to myself, what is the point of this joke? And by point, I mean, what is the message I'm trying to get across in this joke? What's the meaning of it? Not necessarily the funny thing about it.|||谁是讲笑话的人，这是谁的声音？以我在那里的《每日秀》为例，那会是乔恩·斯图尔特。他是节目的主持人。所有的笑话都将由他说出。然后我会试着对自己说，这个笑话的要点是什么？我所指的要点是，我想在这个笑话中传达什么信息？它的含义是什么？不一定是其中有趣的部分。
In fact, often it's the least funny part of the joke. Yeah. And so an example that I was always very proud of myself. too much, so much people would say, is a joke that I wrote for the Daily Show in 2015. There had been a terrorist attack in France, and the United States sent the then Secretary of State John Kerry on a goodwill visit. Secretary of State John Kerry is on a charm offensive this morning in Paris. And the thing about John Kerry is, at the time, he was famous for being very boring and stiff, just a slow talking, like a statue of a man. He's more statue than man.
In fact, often it's the least funny part of the joke. Yeah. And so an example that I was always very proud of myself. too much, so much people would say, is a joke that I wrote for the Daily Show in 2015. There had been a terrorist attack in France, and the United States sent the then Secretary of State John Kerry on a goodwill visit. Secretary of State John Kerry is on a charm offensive this morning in Paris. And the thing about John Kerry is, at the time, he was famous for being very boring and stiff, just a slow talking, like a statue of a man. He's more statue than man.|||事实上，通常它是笑话中最不好笑的部分。是的。所以一个我一直非常为自己感到骄傲的例子——人们会说得太多——是我在2015年为《每日秀》写的一个笑话。法国发生了一起恐怖袭击，美国派时任国务卿约翰·克里进行友好访问。国务卿约翰·克里今天上午在巴黎发动魅力攻势。关于约翰·克里，当时他以无聊和死板而闻名，说话慢吞吞的，就像一尊男人的雕像。他与其说是个人，不如说更像座雕像。
I would like to say directly to the people of Paris and of all of France that each and every American stands with you today, both to the cause of confronting extremism and in the cause which the extremists fear so much. And the first point that jumps into your head is, this is the guy you're sending on a goodwill visit, this guy who is very boring and very unpersonable. But that seemed very obvious. There had to be something less obvious than John Kerry is boring, which at this point at The Daily Show, I think we had told roughly 700,000 million jokes about John Kerry being right. So in looking through the material that we had been given by the researchers and segment producers for this piece, I found this Wolf Blitzer clip where he's reminding us that John Kerry is this enormous Francophile. He loves France. John Kerry speaks French, loves France, studied in France. So the point I decided to go with for this joke is the world's stiffest, least kind of cool man loves everything about the world's sexiest country.
I would like to say directly to the people of Paris and of all of France that each and every American stands with you today, both to the cause of confronting extremism and in the cause which the extremists fear so much. And the first point that jumps into your head is, this is the guy you're sending on a goodwill visit, this guy who is very boring and very unpersonable. But that seemed very obvious. There had to be something less obvious than John Kerry is boring, which at this point at The Daily Show, I think we had told roughly 700,000 million jokes about John Kerry being right. So in looking through the material that we had been given by the researchers and segment producers for this piece, I found this Wolf Blitzer clip where he's reminding us that John Kerry is this enormous Francophile. He loves France. John Kerry speaks French, loves France, studied in France. So the point I decided to go with for this joke is the world's stiffest, least kind of cool man loves everything about the world's sexiest country.|||我想直接对巴黎人民和全法国人民说，每一个美国人都与你们站在一起，既为了对抗极端主义的事业，也为了极端主义极其恐惧的事业。脑海中浮现出的第一点是，这就是你派去进行友好访问的人，这个非常无聊且毫无亲和力的人。但这似乎太显而易见了。一定有什么比“约翰·克里很无聊”更不那么显眼的东西，在《每日秀》的这个阶段，我想我们已经讲了大约七亿个关于约翰·克里很无聊的笑话。因此，在浏览研究员和分段制片人提供给我们的这个片段的素材时，我找到了沃尔夫·布利策的剪辑，他在其中提醒我们，约翰·克里是一个狂热的亲法分子。他热爱法国。约翰·克里会说法语，热爱法国，曾在法国学习。所以我决定在这个笑话中使用的要点是：世界上最死板、最不够酷的男人，热爱世界上最性感国家的切。
Right, right. But that's a point. It's not a, if I say it like that, it's not funny. That's not a joke. No, it's not a joke. It's just me stating a true fact. And so I have to develop a premise to go around it. And a premise is essentially what is the little story that you're going to tell this joke through that gets close to the point, but not.
Right, right. But that's a point. It's not a, if I say it like that, it's not funny. That's not a joke. No, it's not a joke. It's just me stating a true fact. And so I have to develop a premise to go around it. And a premise is essentially what is the little story that you're going to tell this joke through that gets close to the point, but not.|||对的，对的。但那只是一个要点。它不是一个——如果我这么说的话，它并不好笑。那不是一个笑话。不，这不是一个笑话。这只是我在陈述一个真实的事实。所以我必须围绕它开发一个前提。而前提本质上是，你将通过什么小故事来讲这个笑话，这个故事接近要点，但又不会
so close that you're just saying it so that the audience can make a little leap in their minds and they can get it. Like you're setting up a scenario so they will arrive to the point without you telling them the point of the joke. Exactly. And one way I like to think about premises is kind of like, what if scenarios? And so I said to myself, what if John Kerry loves French things so much that as long as the word French is in there, he loves it. French fries, French kissing, French, French horns. And it bakes in the second point that is unrelated to the story that I was covering But it's kind of a funny point still to me, which is there's all this stuff that's not French, but we call it French, right, which is really fun. Okay. So I've got the premise. John Kerry loves everything with French in the name. Now I need structure. And structure is literally the mechanical construction of the joke, how you release each piece of information one step after another in order. So you walk the audience right up to the very edge of the point where they can then make the leap on their own and they land in the joke.
so close that you're just saying it so that the audience can make a little leap in their minds and they can get it. Like you're setting up a scenario so they will arrive to the point without you telling them the point of the joke. Exactly. And one way I like to think about premises is kind of like, what if scenarios? And so I said to myself, what if John Kerry loves French things so much that as long as the word French is in there, he loves it. French fries, French kissing, French, French horns. And it bakes in the second point that is unrelated to the story that I was covering But it's kind of a funny point still to me, which is there's all this stuff that's not French, but we call it French, right, which is really fun. Okay. So I've got the premise. John Kerry loves everything with French in the name. Now I need structure. And structure is literally the mechanical construction of the joke, how you release each piece of information one step after another in order. So you walk the audience right up to the very edge of the point where they can then make the leap on their own and they land in the joke.|||过于接近，以至于你只是把它说出来，好让观众在脑子里做一个小小的飞跃就能明白。就像你在搭建一个场景，这样他们无需你告诉他们笑话的要点，就能自己推导到那个要点。完全正确。我喜欢思考前提的一种方式有点像“如果会怎样”的假设。所以我对自己说，如果约翰·克里如此热爱法国的东西，以至于只要里面有“法国”这个词他就喜欢呢？炸薯条（French fries）、法式热吻（French kissing）、法国（French）、圆号（French horns）。这其中融入了第二个要点，它与我正在报道的故事无关，但对我来说仍然是一个有趣的要点，那就是有这么多东西其实不是法国的，但我们却叫它法国什么什么，对吧，这真的很有趣。好的。所以我有了前提。约翰·克里热爱名字里带“法国”的一切。现在我需要结构。结构实际上就是笑话的机械构造，你是如何按顺序一步步释放每一条信息的。这样你就能引导观众走到要点的边缘，然后他们可以自己完成飞跃，落入笑话之中。
So in writing this John Kerry joke, I started riffing on Wolf Lister's cadence. John Kerry speaks French, loves France, studied in France. I wanted to continue that cadence in a kind of a list, but where John makes it a question-answer thing. Instead of saying, he loves French fries. He loves French bulldogs. Instead, it's favorite type of fries. Favorite type of fries? And the audience fills in French, and he says, French.
So in writing this John Kerry joke, I started riffing on Wolf Lister's cadence. John Kerry speaks French, loves France, studied in France. I wanted to continue that cadence in a kind of a list, but where John makes it a question-answer thing. Instead of saying, he loves French fries. He loves French bulldogs. Instead, it's favorite type of fries. Favorite type of fries? And the audience fills in French, and he says, French.|||所以在写这个约翰·克里笑话时，我开始即兴模仿沃尔夫·利斯特的语调。约翰·克里会说法语，热爱 France，曾在法国学习。我想以一种列表的形式延续那种语调，但在其中约翰将其变成了一个问答的事情。不要说：他喜欢炸薯条。他喜欢法国斗牛犬。相反，它是：最喜欢的薯条类型。最喜欢的薯条类型？观众填空“法国”，他说：法国。
Favorite type of bulldog? Audience fills in French. French. And when you're structuring a joke, you want to do what's called heightening. You want to escalate it from the kind of least funny one or the least exaggerated one to the most exaggerated one. And then you move on to more dramatic examples or sillier examples. Favorite kind of made French! And so I've now established the pattern, French, French, French.
Favorite type of bulldog? Audience fills in French. French. And when you're structuring a joke, you want to do what's called heightening. You want to escalate it from the kind of least funny one or the least exaggerated one to the most exaggerated one. And then you move on to more dramatic examples or sillier examples. Favorite kind of made French! And so I've now established the pattern, French, French, French.|||最喜欢的斗牛犬类型？观众填空“法国”。法国。当你构建一个笑话的结构时，你想做的是所谓的“拔高”。你想把它从最不好笑的或最不夸张的一个升级到最夸张的一个。然后你转到更戏剧化的例子或更愚蠢的例子。最喜欢的法国制造！于是我现在确立了这种模式：法国、法国、法国。
It could go on forever. There's so many French things. But then at the end, I want to subvert that pattern. I want to disrupt it. Right. And so I was like, what do you? if there's something where the answer could be French, but then it isn't French. Got it. Okay, okay.
It could go on forever. There's so many French things. But then at the end, I want to subvert that pattern. I want to disrupt it. Right. And so I was like, what do you? if there's something where the answer could be French, but then it isn't French. Got it. Okay, okay.|||这可以永远持续下去。法国的东西太多了。但最后，我想颠覆这种模式。我想打破它。对的。所以我想的是，如果有什么东西答案本可以是法国的，但结果却不是法国的呢？明白了。好的，好的。
And so there's a kind of mustard called French's mustard. And John Kerry, at the time famously, was married to one of the heirs of the Heinz condiment fortune. So I could say, Favorite mustard! And the audience expects the answer to be French. And then John's going to say, Heinz. Come on, he's not going to jeopardize his marriage over mustard. And so you've taken a joke that specifically about John Kerry. You've made it about, there are a lot of things called French, and then you've taken it back around to being a joke that only works for John Kerry, because only John Kerry is married to
And so there's a kind of mustard called French's mustard. And John Kerry, at the time famously, was married to one of the heirs of the Heinz condiment fortune. So I could say, Favorite mustard! And the audience expects the answer to be French. And then John's going to say, Heinz. Come on, he's not going to jeopardize his marriage over mustard. And so you've taken a joke that specifically about John Kerry. You've made it about, there are a lot of things called French, and then you've taken it back around to being a joke that only works for John Kerry, because only John Kerry is married to|||所以有一种芥末叫法国牌芥末（French's mustard）。而约翰·克里当时以与亨氏调味品财富继承人之一结婚而闻名。所以我可以说：最喜欢的芥末！观众期望答案是“法国”。然后约翰会说：亨氏。得了吧，他才不会为了芥末而危及自己的婚姻。所以你拿了一个专门关于约翰·克里的笑话。你把它变成了关于有很多东西被称为“法国”的笑话，然后你又把它转回一个只对约翰·克里有效的笑话，因为只有约翰·克里娶了
a Heinz. Okay. Yes. And I think the process of working on that took probably less time than it took to describe it, you know, because I was like, here are the steps that I'm going through. And I could design this joke so much faster than I would have otherwise if I was just sitting here trying to think of something to come out of the blue, you know. So, but outside of the Daily Show, I know your book has a lot of examples from, you know,
a Heinz. Okay. Yes. And I think the process of working on that took probably less time than it took to describe it, you know, because I was like, here are the steps that I'm going through. And I could design this joke so much faster than I would have otherwise if I was just sitting here trying to think of something to come out of the blue, you know. So, but outside of the Daily Show, I know your book has a lot of examples from, you know,|||一个亨氏的继承人。好的。是的。而且我认为处理这个过程所花的时间可能比描述它还要少，你知道的，因为我当时想的是：这就是我正在经历的步骤。我可以比我如果没有步骤、只是坐在那里试图凭空想出点什么时快得多地设计出这个笑话。所以，但在《每日秀》之外，我知道你的书里有很多来自，你知道的，
from the world of comedy at large. What are other good examples of somebody using structure to subvert expectation? So most people are familiar, I think, with the kind of structure that you would call set-up punchline. And one of the examples I use in the book is a joke by Rita Rudner, who I think is one of the greatest stand-ups of all time. Totally. I grew up with her. She was one of the standouts of the 80s. She's amazing, yeah.
from the world of comedy at large. What are other good examples of somebody using structure to subvert expectation? So most people are familiar, I think, with the kind of structure that you would call set-up punchline. And one of the examples I use in the book is a joke by Rita Rudner, who I think is one of the greatest stand-ups of all time. Totally. I grew up with her. She was one of the standouts of the 80s. She's amazing, yeah.|||更广阔的喜剧世界的例子。还有哪些人利用结构来颠覆期望的好例子？我认为大多数人都熟悉你会称之为“铺垫-包袱”的结构。我在书中使用的例子之一是丽塔·鲁德纳的一个笑话，我认为她是史上最伟大的单口喜剧演员之一。完全同意。我是看着她的节目长大的。她是80年代的杰出人物之一。她太棒了，是的。
And one of her first jokes, she says, it's going to be a long time for me for children. I'm very single. I was going with someone for a few years, but we broke up. It's one of those things. he wanted to get married and I didn't want him to. But that structure of here's a piece of information
And one of her first jokes, she says, it's going to be a long time for me for children. I'm very single. I was going with someone for a few years, but we broke up. It's one of those things. he wanted to get married and I didn't want him to. But that structure of here's a piece of information|||在她的第一个笑话中，她说，我要有孩子还得等很长一段时间。我非常单身。我和某个人交往了几年，但我们分手了。事情就是这样。他想结婚，而我不想让他结。但这种“这里有一条信息”的结构
and now I'm going to subvert it slightly with the punchline and I'm not going to say I broke with my boyfriend he wanted to get married but he married his other girlfriend like that's not a funny way to say it. But you're surprising the audience
and now I'm going to subvert it slightly with the punchline and I'm not going to say I broke with my boyfriend he wanted to get married but he married his other girlfriend like that's not a funny way to say it. But you're surprising the audience|||现在我用包袱稍微颠覆一下它，我不会说“我和男友分手了，他想结婚但他和他的另一个女友结婚了”，那样说一点也不好笑。但你正在给观众带来惊喜
by providing an answer that is ideally logical but not in the way that the audience originally thought it was going to be I think it's an amazing joke because the sentence that subverts expectations, I didn't want him to. All the meaning of the joke relies on the word him. Yes. And I would say it is a brilliant joke to me because so much of it is packed in that
by providing an answer that is ideally logical but not in the way that the audience originally thought it was going to be I think it's an amazing joke because the sentence that subverts expectations, I didn't want him to. All the meaning of the joke relies on the word him. Yes. And I would say it is a brilliant joke to me because so much of it is packed in that|||通过提供一个在理想情况下合乎逻辑但不是观众最初认为的那种方式的答案。我认为这是一个了不起的笑话，因为那个颠覆期望的句子——“我不想让他（结）”。笑话的所有意义都依赖于“他”这个词。是的。而且我想说，对我来说这是一个绝妙的笑话，因为太多的内涵都打包在那个
word. And the fewer number of words that you can use to deliver a joke, the fewer number of details you can provide, usually the better. You don't want to confuse the audience. And with the clearest, most precise word that you can use. And so there might be that moment where the audience takes a short second to understand it and to complete it for themselves. But that's the moment where the joke lives, that beautiful moment there. In the book, you say that in your joke writing process, there's other elements to a joke that you like to consider beyond the point, the premise, and the structure. So after you figured out that core logic, what comes next?
word. And the fewer number of words that you can use to deliver a joke, the fewer number of details you can provide, usually the better. You don't want to confuse the audience. And with the clearest, most precise word that you can use. And so there might be that moment where the audience takes a short second to understand it and to complete it for themselves. But that's the moment where the joke lives, that beautiful moment there. In the book, you say that in your joke writing process, there's other elements to a joke that you like to consider beyond the point, the premise, and the structure. So after you figured out that core logic, what comes next?|||词中了。你用来讲笑话的词越少，你能提供的细节越少，通常效果就越好。你不想把观众搞糊涂。并且要使用你能用到的最清晰、最精确的词。因此可能会有这样一个时刻，观众花一小秒钟去理解并自己完成它。但那就是笑话赖以生存的时刻，那个美丽的时刻。在书中，你提到在你的笑话创作过程中，除了要点、前提和结构之外，还有其他你喜欢考虑的笑话元素。那么在你想通了那个核心逻辑之后，接下来是什么？
So then we get into what I would call the fiddling with the joke, where you work on the tone of it, kind of like what emotional implications you're trying to get into it. Are you speaking with sincerity or insincerity? What level of irony are you bringing to this? What level of aggression towards the audience or towards the subject of the joke are you bringing? And it's kind of like when you're speaking at a wedding where you're trying to balance the sincerity of your feelings towards the couple that are getting married with the insincerity of the kind of ribbing that you're doing of them. So give me an example of tone and tone management when you're doing a joke. So Don Rickles, for instance, who Don Rickles for the for the younger
So then we get into what I would call the fiddling with the joke, where you work on the tone of it, kind of like what emotional implications you're trying to get into it. Are you speaking with sincerity or insincerity? What level of irony are you bringing to this? What level of aggression towards the audience or towards the subject of the joke are you bringing? And it's kind of like when you're speaking at a wedding where you're trying to balance the sincerity of your feelings towards the couple that are getting married with the insincerity of the kind of ribbing that you're doing of them. So give me an example of tone and tone management when you're doing a joke. So Don Rickles, for instance, who Don Rickles for the for the younger|||接下来我们进入我所说的“润色笑话”环节，在这里你处理它的语调，有点像你想在其中融入什么情感含义。你是带着真诚还是不真诚说话？你给这个带来了什么水平的讽刺？你对观众或对笑话的主题带来了什么程度的攻击性？这有点像你在婚礼上发言时，你试图平衡你对结婚新人的真诚情感与你对他们进行取笑的不真诚。那么能给我举一个你在讲笑话时关于语调和语调管理的例子吗？比如唐·里克斯，唐·里克斯对于年轻的
members of the listenership, if they don't know. Don Rickles was the master of insult comedy that was just so aggressively over-the-top hostile that you could not take it seriously as real actual hostility. Am I right? His wife and your wife have the same name, Frank's wife and your wife? What are you, a detective? Yeah, I'm a detective. That's right.
members of the listenership, if they don't know. Don Rickles was the master of insult comedy that was just so aggressively over-the-top hostile that you could not take it seriously as real actual hostility. Am I right? His wife and your wife have the same name, Frank's wife and your wife? What are you, a detective? Yeah, I'm a detective. That's right.|||听众来说，如果他们不知道的话。唐·里克斯是侮辱性喜剧的大师，这种喜剧极具攻击性、过分敌对，以至于你无法把它当作真正的敌意来认真对待。我说的对吗？他妻子和你的妻子同名，弗兰克的妻子和你的妻子？你是什么，侦探吗？对，我是个侦探。没错。
I mean, you come up with these remarks. They have the same name. Something. Now, Denzel was There's medication for that day Whereas sometimes The more deadpan you are
I mean, you come up with these remarks. They have the same name. Something. Now, Denzel was There's medication for that day Whereas sometimes The more deadpan you are|||我的意思是，你想出这些言论。它们同名。什么的。现在，丹泽尔是 那天有药吃 而有时 你越面无表情
Like with a comedian like Stephen Wright Who I think is a master But his stuff is so deadpan That you're like, well, obviously He didn't really do these things I called the wrong number today I said, hello, is Joey there? And a woman answered, she said, yes, he is.
Like with a comedian like Stephen Wright Who I think is a master But his stuff is so deadpan That you're like, well, obviously He didn't really do these things I called the wrong number today I said, hello, is Joey there? And a woman answered, she said, yes, he is.|||就像斯蒂芬·赖特这样的喜剧演员，我认为他是一位大师，但他的东西太面无表情了，以至于你会觉得，好吧，很明显他并没有真的做过这些事情。我今天打错了电话。我说，喂，乔伊在吗？一个女人接了电话，她说，是的，他在。
I said, can I speak to him, please? She said, no, he can't talk right? Right now, he's only two months old. I said, all right, I'll wait. I mean, who is telling the joke is, it's maybe not as important as the joke itself, but it's like up there. It's, who is telling the joke is the first piece of information that the audience gets about the joke. Who is this person? What do I assume their perspective that they're bringing to it is?
I said, can I speak to him, please? She said, no, he can't talk right? Right now, he's only two months old. I said, all right, I'll wait. I mean, who is telling the joke is, it's maybe not as important as the joke itself, but it's like up there. It's, who is telling the joke is the first piece of information that the audience gets about the joke. Who is this person? What do I assume their perspective that they're bringing to it is?|||我说，我能和他说话吗？她说，不，他现在不能说话。现在他才两个月大。我说，好吧，我等。我的意思是，谁在讲笑话，它可能不像笑话本身那么重要，但它也居于高位。它是，谁在讲笑话是观众关于笑话获得的第一个信息。这个人是谁？我假设他们带入其中的视角是什么？
And in the book I talk about kind of like stand-up persona and how it can help. become the context for the tone of a joke. And an example of this that I use in the book is Charlie Hill, who is another great comic, who is a member of the Oneida Nation. No, a lot of you, white people, never seen an Indian do stand-up comedy before, you know? Like for so long, you probably thought
And in the book I talk about kind of like stand-up persona and how it can help. become the context for the tone of a joke. And an example of this that I use in the book is Charlie Hill, who is another great comic, who is a member of the Oneida Nation. No, a lot of you, white people, never seen an Indian do stand-up comedy before, you know? Like for so long, you probably thought|||在书中我谈到了类似于单口喜剧人设的内容，以及它如何帮助成为笑话语调的背景。我在书中用到的一个例子是查理·希尔，他是另一位伟大的喜剧演员，奥奈达部族的成员。不，你们很多白人以前从未见过印第安人表演单口喜剧，你知道吗？就像这么长时间以来，你可能认为
that Indians never had a sense of humor, you know? We never thought you were too funny either. He was on a talk show in the 70s, and they asked him if he ever played Cowboying Indians, which is, I wish I hope was a setup that he provided for them and not an actual question that they were asking him. And he said, no, we never played Cowboys and Indians, but we did play Nazis and Jews. The rules are the same.
that Indians never had a sense of humor, you know? We never thought you were too funny either. He was on a talk show in the 70s, and they asked him if he ever played Cowboying Indians, which is, I wish I hope was a setup that he provided for them and not an actual question that they were asking him. And he said, no, we never played Cowboys and Indians, but we did play Nazis and Jews. The rules are the same.|||印第安人从来没有幽默感，你知道吗？我们以前也觉得你们没那么好笑。他在70年代的一个脱口秀节目中，他们问他是否玩过牛仔大战印第安人，这是一个——我希望这是他为他们提供的一个铺垫，而不是他们实际问他的问题。他说，不，我们从来不玩牛仔和印第安人，但我们确实玩过纳粹和犹太人。规则是一样的。
And that's a harsh. I love that joke. That's a hard joke. But it's a coming from someone who is bringing the perspective of a Native American and indigenous person, it means a certain thing. It is not a joke that means to make a joke about the ideas of Nazis killing Jews. It is instead about reframing this childhood game that makes light of genocide in the light of. in the light of another genocide that the audience recognizes.
And that's a harsh. I love that joke. That's a hard joke. But it's a coming from someone who is bringing the perspective of a Native American and indigenous person, it means a certain thing. It is not a joke that means to make a joke about the ideas of Nazis killing Jews. It is instead about reframing this childhood game that makes light of genocide in the light of. in the light of another genocide that the audience recognizes.|||这是一个尖锐的笑话。我喜欢那个笑话。那是个重口味的笑话。但它出自一个带有美洲原住民和土著人视角的人之口，这意味着某种特定的东西。这不是一个旨在拿纳粹屠杀犹太人的想法开玩笑的笑话。相反，它是关于在另一个观众认可的种族灭绝的背景下，重新构建这个轻描淡写种族灭绝的童年游戏。
But in a funny way, as a funny joke. And the fact that is coming from Charlie Hill means we understand what he's getting at. And this leads us to the audience, which is like the completion of the joke, which is essentially like the last part and the most important part. It's the most important.
But in a funny way, as a funny joke. And the fact that is coming from Charlie Hill means we understand what he's getting at. And this leads us to the audience, which is like the completion of the joke, which is essentially like the last part and the most important part. It's the most important.|||但以一种有趣的方式，作为一个有趣的笑话。而且这个笑话出自查理·希尔之手，意味着我们理解他的意图。这就把我们引向了观众，这就像是笑话的完成，本质上就像是最后一部分，也是最重要的一部分。它是最重要的。
Unfortunately, it's the most important part. And like nobody, you can't tell a joke on your own. Like the audience provides the most important part of the joke, which is the person laughing at the joke. And there's something very depressingly humbly about the idea that, like, you don't get to decide ultimately if your work is funny or not. Like, the audience gets to decide.
Unfortunately, it's the most important part. And like nobody, you can't tell a joke on your own. Like the audience provides the most important part of the joke, which is the person laughing at the joke. And there's something very depressingly humbly about the idea that, like, you don't get to decide ultimately if your work is funny or not. Like, the audience gets to decide.|||不幸的是，它是最重要的一部分。就像没有人，你无法独自讲笑话。就像观众提供了笑话中最重要的一部分，那就是对笑话发出笑声的那个人。有一个非常令人沮丧但又谦卑的想法，那就是，你最终无法决定你的作品是否有趣。观众才有权决定。
And if they're not laughing, then you've failed them. But they also, the audience wants to laugh. And that was such a big thing for me when I was performing stand-up was remembering the audience is not there to get mad at me. They're not challenging me. They might be a little bit,
And if they're not laughing, then you've failed them. But they also, the audience wants to laugh. And that was such a big thing for me when I was performing stand-up was remembering the audience is not there to get mad at me. They're not challenging me. They might be a little bit,|||如果他们没有笑，那么你就让他们失望了。但他们也一样，观众想要笑。当我表演单口喜剧时，对我来说最重要的一点就是记住观众不是来生我的气的。他们不是在挑战我。他们可能有一点点，
but they want the joke writer or the performer to succeed because it's more fun for them. Yeah. And you want to succeed by, maybe challenging what they're going to laugh at a little bit, but not challenging it so much that you're deliberately bombing. There's some comedians who love to bomb. It's very fun if you're a comedian to watch another comedian bomb,
but they want the joke writer or the performer to succeed because it's more fun for them. Yeah. And you want to succeed by, maybe challenging what they're going to laugh at a little bit, but not challenging it so much that you're deliberately bombing. There's some comedians who love to bomb. It's very fun if you're a comedian to watch another comedian bomb,|||但他们希望笑话创作者或表演者成功，因为这对他们来说更有趣。是的。而你想通过以下方式取得成功：也许稍微挑战一下他们会笑的东西，但不要挑战得太过分以至于故意砸场子。有些喜剧演员喜欢砸场子。如果你是一名喜剧演员，看另一个喜剧演员砸场子是非常有趣的，
but only because then you become the audience. The audience becomes the punchline to the joke, and you become the audience of watching the joke of an audience not getting a joke. And that's why when I was young, I kind of was very frustrated with Andy Kaufman's comedy because it was like, Andy Kaufman is both the joke teller and the audience. Like, it is all about his reaction or his enjoyment of the audience. is confusion.
only because then you become the audience. The audience becomes the punchline to the joke, and you become the audience of watching the joke of an audience not getting a joke. And that's why when I was young, I kind of was very frustrated with Andy Kaufman's comedy because it was like, Andy Kaufman is both the joke teller and the audience. Like, it is all about his reaction or his enjoyment of the audience. is confusion.|||仅仅因为那样你就成了观众。观众变成了笑话的包袱，而你成了观看“观众没听懂笑话”这个笑话的观众。这就是为什么当我年轻的时候，我对安迪·考夫曼的喜剧感到非常沮丧，因为这就像是，安迪·考夫曼既是讲笑话的人又是观众。这完全取决于他的反应或他对观众的享受。那是困惑。
I don't understand one thing. No, seriously. Why everyone is going boo on, like, the joke, when I told some of the jokes, and then when I don't want you to laugh, you're laughing. Like right now, you don't understand. Now I kind of like it. Now I think it's kind of funny,
I don't understand one thing. No, seriously. Why everyone is going boo on, like, the joke, when I told some of the jokes, and then when I don't want you to laugh, you're laughing. Like right now, you don't understand. Now I kind of like it. Now I think it's kind of funny,|||有一件事我不明白。不，说真的。为什么当我说了一些笑话时，所有人都在发出嘘声，而当我不希望你们笑时，你们却在笑。就像现在这样，你们不明白。现在我有点喜欢它了。现在我觉得这挺有趣的，
because it makes the audience such an integral part of that material. I had other stuff I was going to do. for you, but I don't think I should. So I just want to say thank you. And, you know, I'm just trying to do, you don't have to say that, really, okay? I'm just trying to do my best to have some fun. And if you don't like it, that's it. Okay, thank you very much and good night. I mean, one of the reasons why Andy Kaufman ends up working is you could see the sort of anti-comedy stuff where it seems like it's just for his own benefit. But in a totally another act, you could see just how funny he is and bringing the people in when he wants to.
because it makes the audience such an integral part of that material. I had other stuff I was going to do. for you, but I don't think I should. So I just want to say thank you. And, you know, I'm just trying to do, you don't have to say that, really, okay? I'm just trying to do my best to have some fun. And if you don't like it, that's it. Okay, thank you very much and good night. I mean, one of the reasons why Andy Kaufman ends up working is you could see the sort of anti-comedy stuff where it seems like it's just for his own benefit. But in a totally another act, you could see just how funny he is and bringing the people in when he wants to.|||因为它让观众成为该素材不可或缺的一部分。我本来还有其他事情要为你做。但我认为我不应该这样做。所以我只想说谢谢。而且，你知道的，我只是在努力做，你真的不用那么说，好吧？我只是在尽力找点乐子。如果你不喜欢，那就是这样。好的，非常感谢，晚安。我的意思是，安迪·考夫曼最终行之有效的原因之一是，你可以看到那种反喜剧的东西，它似乎只对他自己有利。但在完全不同的表演中，你可以看到他是多么有趣，并在他想的时候把人们拉进来。
The first audience for all of Andy Kaufman's bits, they are the first wave at D-Day that get mowed down and never have a chance so that the next wave of audience members can understand it and laugh at the joke, you know. But even then, it's a matter of delivering information to the audience. And the audience will give you thoughts that are sometimes wrong. If the audience says, I didn't like that you talked about this thing, then that's not a good note but if the note is
The first audience for all of Andy Kaufman's bits, they are the first wave at D-Day that get mowed down and never have a chance so that the next wave of audience members can understand it and laugh at the joke, you know. But even then, it's a matter of delivering information to the audience. And the audience will give you thoughts that are sometimes wrong. If the audience says, I didn't like that you talked about this thing, then that's not a good note but if the note is|||安迪·考夫曼所有段子的第一批观众，他们就是D日的冲锋第一波，被机枪扫射倒下，根本没有机会，这样下一波观众才能理解并对笑话笑出来，你知道的。但即便如此，这依然是将信息传递给观众的问题。而观众会给你有时是错误的反馈。如果观众说：“我不喜欢你谈论这件事，”那这就不是一个好的意见，但如果意见是
I didn't think that was funny the way you talked about it then that's a good note because then you're not communicating the absurdity you're seeing properly to the audience could you give an example of audience feedback
I didn't think that was funny the way you talked about it then that's a good note because then you're not communicating the absurdity you're seeing properly to the audience could you give an example of audience feedback|||“我觉得你谈论它的方式一点也不好笑”，那这就是一个好意见，因为那意味着你没有把所看到的荒谬感正确地传达给观众。你能举一个观众反馈的例子吗？
that was valuable to you some of the most audience feedback I got was when I was working on the Netflix seasons of Mystery Science Theater 2000 and Mystery Science Theater was the show I wanted to work on since I was a teenager
that was valuable to you some of the most audience feedback I got was when I was working on the Netflix seasons of Mystery Science Theater 2000 and Mystery Science Theater was the show I wanted to work on since I was a teenager|||对你很有价值的？我得到过最有价值的观众反馈，是我在参与Netflix版《神秘科学剧场3000》工作的时候。《神秘科学剧场》是我从十几岁起就一直想参与制作的节目。
I felt really so grateful that I got to work on it And when we were working on that first season, I was like, this is my philosophy. Max jokes. That's what I used to call it in the room. Maximum jokes. Let's see how many jokes we could fit in there. And we put in just wall-to-wall jokes.
I felt really so grateful that I got to work on it And when we were working on that first season, I was like, this is my philosophy. Max jokes. That's what I used to call it in the room. Maximum jokes. Let's see how many jokes we could fit in there. And we put in just wall-to-wall jokes.|||我真的非常感激能有机会参与其中。当我们制作第一季时，我想，这就是我的哲学。极致笑话。这就是我以前在房间里对它的称呼。笑话最大化。让我们看看能在里面塞进多少笑话。于是我们塞满了密密麻麻的笑话。
It's like how the wire taught me how crime works. Now I'm good at crime. I can't identify you by your chest hair. Oh, I was the one shooting you. Oh. Ah, now the guns on the other foot. You just got narcoed. And the feedback we got from the audience was, there's too many jokes in this show.
It's like how the wire taught me how crime works. Now I'm good at crime. I can't identify you by your chest hair. Oh, I was the one shooting you. Oh. Ah, now the guns on the other foot. You just got narcoed. And the feedback we got from the audience was, there's too many jokes in this show.|||就像《火线》教我犯罪是如何运作的一样。现在我很擅长犯罪。我无法通过你的胸毛认出你。哦，开枪打你的人是我。哦。啊，现在风水轮流转了。你刚中了毒品局的招。而我们从观众那里得到的反馈是：这个节目里的笑话太多了。
that like I can't because I don't have time to process each joke before the next one comes. I don't have time to really sit in that joke and laugh at it and then I'm missing the next one. And that was a good note because there's something important about the time after a joke and the time before the next joke and the timing of that. And so for the second season of that show, if it felt like there were too many jokes too close together, I'd weed them out. And Joel Hodgson, the creator of that show, he started calling me the joke killer. I'd be like, we should, we should take these out. And he's like, oh, the joke killer is at it again. But it was a matter of kind of thinning the herd so that the strongest jokes have their chance to get their best moment in the sun.
that like I can't because I don't have time to process each joke before the next one comes. I don't have time to really sit in that joke and laugh at it and then I'm missing the next one. And that was a good note because there's something important about the time after a joke and the time before the next joke and the timing of that. And so for the second season of that show, if it felt like there were too many jokes too close together, I'd weed them out. And Joel Hodgson, the creator of that show, he started calling me the joke killer. I'd be like, we should, we should take these out. And he's like, oh, the joke killer is at it again. But it was a matter of kind of thinning the herd so that the strongest jokes have their chance to get their best moment in the sun.|||以至于我不能……因为在下一个笑话到来之前，我没有时间去消化每一个笑话。我没有时间真正去体会那个笑话并为之发笑，然后我就错过了下一个。这是一个很好的意见，因为笑话之后的时间和下一个笑话之前的时间以及其中的时机非常重要。所以在该节目的第二季中，如果感觉笑话太多太密集，我就会剔除它们。该节目的创作者乔尔·霍奇森开始叫我“笑话终结者”。我会说：我们应该，我们应该把这些去掉。而他说：哦，笑话终结者又来了。但这属于大浪淘沙，让最强的笑话有机会在阳光下展现它们的高光时刻。
When we come back, we talk to Elliot about what his fellow comedy writers think of his system and how comedians can use comedy for good and evil. Stay with us. We are back with my sometimes co-host and always brilliant comedy writer Elliot Kalin. So Elliot earlier, you kind of laid out the elements of what you call joke farming, and there's a few of them. There's the identity, the idea, the premise, the structure, the tone, the voice, the wording, the audience. Like, this is a process. It is developed. So I am curious, were your fellow writers on the Daily Show?
When we come back, we talk to Elliot about what his fellow comedy writers think of his system and how comedians can use comedy for good and evil. Stay with us. We are back with my sometimes co-host and always brilliant comedy writer Elliot Kalin. So Elliot earlier, you kind of laid out the elements of what you call joke farming, and there's a few of them. There's the identity, the idea, the premise, the structure, the tone, the voice, the wording, the audience. Like, this is a process. It is developed. So I am curious, were your fellow writers on the Daily Show?|||广告回来后，我们将与埃利奥特探讨他的同行喜剧编剧对他的系统有何看法，以及喜剧演员如何将喜剧用于善恶两途。请继续收看。我们回来了，和我有时搭档、才华横溢的喜剧编剧埃利奥特·卡林在一起。埃利奥特，刚才你大致列出了你所谓的“笑话耕作”的要素，有好几个。有身份、构思、前提、结构、语调、声音、措辞、观众。这是一个流程。它是经过开发的。所以我很好奇，《每日秀》的其他编剧，
show, aware that you were going through all these steps in your head? Like, were they aware that you were joke farming? No, not really. I mean, by that time I was the head writer on the show, and some of the writers I would talk to about, like, let's try to think systematically about the way we're doing things, so you can increase your hit rate. But often, they were not that interested in it. I mean, more because when you're a comedy writer, I think it is hard sometimes to think
show, aware that you were going through all these steps in your head? Like, were they aware that you were joke farming? No, not really. I mean, by that time I was the head writer on the show, and some of the writers I would talk to about, like, let's try to think systematically about the way we doing things, so you can increase your hit rate. But often, they were not that interested in it. I mean, more because when you're a comedy writer, I think it is hard sometimes to think|||节目里的其他人，知道你脑子里在经历所有这些步骤吗？比如说，他们知道你在进行“笑话耕作”吗？不，其实不知道。我的意思是，到那时我是节目的首席编剧，我会和一些编剧谈论，比如，让我们试着系统地思考我们做事的方式，这样你可以提高命中率。但通常，他们对此并不是很感兴趣。我的意思是，更多是因为当你成为一名喜剧演员或喜剧编剧时，有时很难去思考
of what you're doing as engineering in that way, as something that you can do that way. And you kind of don't want to think about it that way sometimes because I think there's a fear that if you question where the inspiration is coming from, if you try to control it, that you might lose it, it might go away. You know, it's a miracle that you don't control. And I feel like every comedy person has this fear in the back of their head that someday, one day they'll wake up and they won't know how to be funny anymore. And there's a old saying from, I think, E.B. White about explaining how a joke works is like dissecting a fraud. like, it's not good for the frog, you know.
of what you're doing as engineering in that way, as something that you can do that way. And you kind of don't want to think about it that way sometimes because I think there's a fear that if you question where the inspiration is coming from, if you try to control it, that you might lose it, it might go away. You know, it's a miracle that you don't control. And I feel like every comedy person has this fear in the back of their head that someday, one day they'll wake up and they won't know how to be funny anymore. And there's a old saying from, I think, E.B. White about explaining how a joke works is like dissecting a fraud. like, it's not good for the frog, you know.|||你正在做的事情就像那种工程学一样，是一件你可以那样做的事情。而且有时你有点不想那样去想，因为我认为有一种恐惧：如果你去追问灵感从何而来，如果你试图控制它，你可能会失去它，它可能会消失。你知道的，那是一个你无法控制的奇迹。我觉得每一个喜剧人都有一种深藏脑海的恐惧，那就是总有一天，他们醒来后会突然不知道该怎么搞笑了。我记得E·B·怀特有一句老话，关于解释笑话是如何运作的就像解剖青蛙一样：这对青蛙可没好处，你知道的。
I don't agree with that. But I think a lot of people have internalized that idea. But also, at the same time, there are a number of comedy professionals I met who are, they're not so interested in figuring out their own process, but they are very fascinated by how other people do their process. And the thing you always hear about Jerry Seinfeld, or you used to hear about Jerry Seinfeld was he actually sits down and writes. Like, he sits down every day for a couple hours and just writes and works.
I don't agree with that. But I think a lot of people have internalized that idea. But also, at the same time, there are a number of comedy professionals I met who are, they're not so interested in figuring out their own process, but they are very fascinated by how other people do their process. And the thing you always hear about Jerry Seinfeld, or you used to hear about Jerry Seinfeld was he actually sits down and writes. Like, he sits down every day for a couple hours and just writes and works.|||我不同意这种说法。但我认为很多人已经内化了这种观念。但同时，我遇到过一些喜剧专业人士，他们对摸索自己的流程兴趣不大，但他们对其他人是如何进行他们的流程非常着迷。你总是听到关于杰瑞·宋飞的事情，或者过去常听到关于杰瑞·宋飞的事情是，他真的坐下来写作。比如，他每天坐下来几个小时，只是写作和工作。
He doesn't carry around a notebook and just wait for something to hit him and then work it out on stage. Like, he writes it out. And so I think there is an interest on the part of professionals in other people's way of doing that craft. It's funny to me that when people reveal that Jerry Seinfeld actually writes that Joan Rivers has a card catalog full of, you know, 10,000 jokes or something like that, that it's surprising to people because they just think of them as funny people when the best at this definitely know their craft. And even if they don't write it out in steps like you do in terms of joke farming. They're basically joke farming. Yes. Or at the very least, joke foraging where they are, you know, they're keeping
He doesn't carry around a notebook and just wait for something to hit him and then work it out on stage. Like, he writes it out. And so I think there is an interest on the part of professionals in other people's way of doing that craft. It's funny to me that when people reveal that Jerry Seinfeld actually writes that Joan Rivers has a card catalog full of, you know, 10,000 jokes or something like that, that it's surprising to people because they just think of them as funny people when the best at this definitely know their craft. And even if they don't write it out in steps like you do in terms of joke farming. They're basically joke farming. Yes. Or at the very least, joke foraging where they are, you know, they're keeping|||他不会随身带着笔记本，只是等着有什么东西击中他，然后在舞台上即兴发挥。相反，他把它写出来。所以我认为专业人士对其他人做这种手艺的方式很感兴趣。对我来说有趣的是，当人们透露杰瑞·宋飞实际上会动笔写作，琼·里弗斯有一个装满，你知道的，一万个笑话的卡片目录时，人们会感到惊讶，因为他们只把他们当作搞笑的人，而这方面的顶尖高手绝对精通他们的手艺。即使他们不像你在笑话耕作方面那样一步步写出来。他们基本上也在进行笑话耕作。是的。或者至少可以说是“笑话觅食”，他们在那里，你知道的，他们一直在
their eye open to the world around them for opportunities for things to tell jokes about. I think there's an attempt to work very hard at something and then make it look as if no work has been put into it. And that's the real magic of it. The illusion that someone is up on stage and they're just riffing, they're just speaking their truth or whatever. And it's just coming out so funny, but I think that illusion is part of the craft of it. And I know that when I read prose or when I watch stand-ups, even I as an audience member, I'm like, oh, God, I wish I was as good as them because they're just talking and it's funny. Like, they must have put no work into that at all. And then I have to remember like, no, they obviously put work into it. Well, I want to
their eye open to the world around them for opportunities for things to tell jokes about. I think there's an attempt to work very hard at something and then make it look as if no work has been put into it. And that's the real magic of it. The illusion that someone is up on stage and they're just riffing, they're just speaking their truth or whatever. And it's just coming out so funny, but I think that illusion is part of the craft of it. And I know that when I read prose or when I watch stand-ups, even I as an audience member, I'm like, oh, God, I wish I was as good as them because they're just talking and it's funny. Like, they must have put no work into that at all. And then I have to remember like, no, they obviously put work into it. Well, I want to|||睁大眼睛观察周围的世界，寻找可以用来讲笑话的机会。我认为有一种尝试是：在某件事情上非常努力地工作，然后让它看起来好像没有付出任何努力。这才是真正的魔力所在。那种“某人站在舞台上，他们只是在即兴发挥，他们只是在说出自己的真相或别的什么，而且它就这么好笑”的幻觉，但我认为这种幻觉也是其手艺的一部分。我知道当我读散文或看单口喜剧时，即使作为观众的我，也会想：哦，天哪，我希望我能和他们一样好，因为他们只是在聊天就很好笑。好像他们根本没有为之付出任何努力。然后我不得不提醒自己：不，他们显然为之付出了努力。好吧，我想
talk about one thing you mentioned in the book, which is this ability to use these techniques of joke-telling for evil purposes? I wouldn't advise it. I don't recommend people use it for evil. Yeah, but how do they use for evil purposes? Well, I mean, joke writing, joke-telling, it's just a tool. And so I think there are bad people who use comedy to get bad effects. And I think the misunderstanding is, if it's funny, it must be right.
talk about one thing you mentioned in the book, which is this ability to use these techniques of joke-telling for evil purposes? I wouldn't advise it. I don't recommend people use it for evil. Yeah, but how do they use for evil purposes? Well, I mean, joke writing, joke-telling, it's just a tool. And so I think there are bad people who use comedy to get bad effects. And I think the misunderstanding is, if it's funny, it must be right.|||谈谈你在书中提到的一件事，那就是利用这些讲笑话的技巧来达到邪恶目的的能力？我不建议这么做。我不推荐人们为了邪恶的目的使用它。是的，但他们是如何将其用于邪恶目的的呢？嗯，我的意思是，写笑话，讲笑话，它只是一种工具。所以我认为有些坏人利用喜剧来达到坏的效果。我认为误解在于：如果它好笑，那它一定是对的。
It must be getting at something that I believe, which I think is not true. And comedians for a long time, they liked to puff themselves up about like, well, really comedy is about speaking truth to power and you always punch up you never punch down it's not funny to punch down and it's like have you met a bully
It must be getting at something that I believe, which I think is not true. And comedians for a long time, they liked to puff themselves up about like, well, really comedy is about speaking truth to power and you always punch up you never punch down it's not funny to punch down and it's like have you met a bully|||它一定触及了某些我相信的东西，而我认为事实并非如此。很长一段时间以来，喜剧演员喜欢自我吹嘘，比如：喜剧实际上是对强权说真话，你总是向上攻击，绝不向下攻击，向下攻击一点都不好笑。这就好比：你见过霸凌者吗？
like a lot of people like to punch down and they find it very funny and you can't say well they don't count because they're not funny because somebody finds them funny even if you don't
like a lot of people like to punch down and they find it very funny and you can't say well they don't count because they're not funny because somebody finds them funny even if you don't|||就像很多人喜欢向下攻击一样，他们觉得这非常有趣，你不能说“他们不算数，因为他们并不好笑”，因为总有人觉得他们好笑，即使你并不觉得。
like why did Donald Trump become such a successful candidate partly because a lot of people found him very funny and he had one joke during his campaign that I thought was very funny
like why did Donald Trump become such a successful candidate partly because a lot of people found him very funny and he had one joke during his campaign that I thought was very funny|||为什么唐纳德·特朗普会成为如此成功的候选人？部分原因是因为很多人觉得他非常搞笑，他在竞选期间有一个笑话，我认为非常搞笑
that was just straightforward stand-up comedy where he was in I think Cleveland and he's like He's like, I'm in Cleveland. I need your vote. Wouldn't be in Cleveland if I didn't need your vote.
that was just straightforward stand-up comedy where he was in I think Cleveland and he's like He's like, I'm in Cleveland. I need your vote. Wouldn't be in Cleveland if I didn't need your vote.|||那是非常直接的单口喜剧，当时他在克利夫兰，我想，他说：他在克利夫兰。他说：我在克利夫兰。我需要你们的选票。如果我不需要你们的选票，才不会来克利夫兰呢。
You think I'd be in Cleveland if I didn't need your vote? No, I wouldn't. And like, that's just standard stand-up, just roasting the town they're in. And I was like, you know, that's a funny joke. But it's being used for evil. But, you know, like any communication tool or any work of art, it can embody terrible things and still be an example of craft. This reminds me of something that just the power of the joke as a structure and how it elicit. It's a response.
You think I'd be in Cleveland if I didn't need your vote? No, I wouldn't. And like, that's just standard stand-up, just roasting the town they're in. And I was like, you know, that's a funny joke. But it's being used for evil. But, you know, like any communication tool or any work of art, it can embody terrible things and still be an example of craft. This reminds me of something that just the power of the joke as a structure and how it elicit. It's a response.|||你觉得如果我不需要你们的选票我会来克利夫兰吗？不，我不会。就像，那是标准的单口喜剧，只是在吐槽他们所在的城镇。当时我想，你知道的，那是个好笑的笑话。但它被用于邪恶的目的。但是，你知道的，就像任何沟通工具或任何艺术品一样，它可以体现可怕的东西，却仍然可以是一个手艺的例子。这让我想起了一点：仅仅作为结构的笑话的力量，以及它是如何引发反应的。
This reminds me of one time I was doing this. Is this a real story or a joke? This is a real story. One time I was on the way to an interview and the craziest thing happened. No, but I was doing an interview and it was about these seed banks that store all of all the seeds that are in the world so that if something catastrophic happens, they have all the seeds in this safe place so that it can replace the plant life that's been destroyed. And it was talking about the one in Svalbard, which is this remote, you know, like Arctic Island. And it was so cherished and protected. And it's there underground in a vault.
This reminds me of one time I was doing this. Is this a real story or a joke? This is a real story. One time I was on the way to an interview and the craziest thing happened. No, but I was doing an interview and it was about these seed banks that store all of all the seeds that are in the world so that if something catastrophic happens, they have all the seeds in this safe place so that it can replace the plant life that's been destroyed. And it was talking about the one in Svalbard, which is this remote, you know, like Arctic Island. And it was so cherished and protected. And it's there underground in a vault.|||这让我想起有一次我正在做这件事。这是一个真实的故事还是个笑话？这是一个真实的故事。有一次我在去采访的路上，发生了最疯狂的事情。不，但我当时在做一次采访，内容是关于这些种子库的，它们储存了世界上所有的种子，以便如果发生灾难性的事情，它们在这个安全的地方拥有所有的种子，这样它就可以替代被摧毁的植物生命。它谈到了斯瓦尔巴特群岛的那个种子库，那是一个偏远的、你知道的，像北极岛屿一样的地方。它是如此受珍视和保护。它就在那里的地下保险库里。
And then I asked, well, there's another one. Like, where was the other one? And the person said, oh, Aleppo. And I laughed because Aleppo was undergoing this intense civil war where a bunch of people were dying. And it's just the structure of a joke of just like, we're going to describe the safest place that the seeds are safe. And then and then the other one is in O'Leppo. And I laugh. They're like, we have the, we have it. It's in the most extreme maximum security. Where's the other one? Oh, a toddler keeps it in his pants. That's exactly it. Okay. So, so it was a genuine reaction. We put it out on the air. And Assyrian
然后我问，嗯，还有一个。比如，另一个在哪里？那个人说，哦，阿勒颇。我笑了，因为阿勒颇当时正在经历激烈的内战，很多人在那里丧生。这就像是一个笑话的结构，就像是我们要描述种子最安全的地方。然后，然后另一个在阿勒颇。我笑了。他们就像是，我们有，我们得到了。它在最极端的最高安全级别。另一个在哪里？哦，一个幼儿把它塞在裤子里。就是这样。好吧。所以，这是一个真实的反应。我们把它播出了，然后一个亚述人
wrote me and said, it really broke my heart that you laughed at that. And part of me was like, I get it. I get, I get what you're saying. But I couldn't. help it. Like, it was a joke set up almost. And it's sort of the, the nature of the structure of a joke is so powerful that I was definitely not making fun of Aleppo or thinking about their suffering. I was definitely thinking of it is like putting in the pants of a toddler, you know, in the sense of it. Well, you were thinking of it in terms of the pattern that had been set up. They had set up the pattern of these seeds are the most precious thing and we have to keep them in the safest possible place. And then the subversion of that pattern, which is
写信给我说，你笑这个让我真的很心碎。我心里有一部分觉得，我懂，我懂，我懂你的意思。但我忍不住。就像，这几乎是一个笑话的设定。而且笑话结构的这种本质是如此强大，我绝对不是在取笑阿勒颇，也没有去想他们的苦难。我绝对是在想把它塞进幼儿裤子里的那种感觉，你知道的，从这个意义上说。嗯，你是在考虑已经建立的模式。他们设定了这样一种模式：这些种子是最珍贵的，我们必须把它们放在最安全的地方。然后是这种模式的颠覆，也就是
Aleppo. And you're right that you were laughing at the structure of that joke. You were not laughing at the tragedy of what was going on at the time. But at the same time, you can't fault the emotional reaction of that audience member. If they have an individual reaction to the content of the joke, what the joke is about, how it said, you can't fault that because the audience is ultimately the decider for themselves of what is funny or not. They have a sense of humor. It's not a science of humor. It's a sense. You know, and it's individual for everyone. Elliot, I got to say, I love this book. I loved learning how your mind works a little bit more. And I'm curious, what do you want people to get out of it who are not going to be paid joke writers ever in their life? My hope is that first that you enjoy it. First that you laugh. It's a funny book. It is. And first that you laugh at and enjoy it. That's a funny thing. Like, because the thing is that people should recognize is when you're dissecting jokes and telling people how to write jokes. As examples, you use jokes. And so, therefore, it has tons of jokes in it. And you have. a wide-reaching survey of comedy of the last few decades. I was trying very hard to get a wide variety of people, comedy types, comedy mediums, but even then, it's still just scratching the surface because there's so much. Comedy is so enormous. The comedy you see on TikTok is very much the same as comedy you see in a stand-up, comedy you see in a funny movie, comedy you read. I use an example from the book Tristam Shandy by Lawrence Stern, which is a hilarious book, but
阿勒颇。你说得对，你在笑那个笑话的结构。你不是在笑当时发生的悲剧。但与此同时，你不能责怪那个听众的情绪反应。如果他们对笑话的内容、笑话讲的是什么、它是怎么讲的产生了个人反应，你不能责怪这一点，因为听众最终是决定什么好笑、什么不好笑的人。他们有幽默感。这不是一门幽默科学。这是一种感觉。你知道的，这因人而异。埃利奥特，我得说，我太喜欢这本书了。我很高兴能更多地了解你的思维方式。我很好奇，对于那些这辈子永远不会成为付费笑话编剧的人来说，你希望他们从中收获什么？我的希望是首先你能享受它。首先你会笑。这是一本有趣的书。确实是。首先你会笑并享受它。这是一件有趣的事。因为人们应该认识到的是，当你剖析笑话并告诉人们如何写笑话时。作为例子，你会使用笑话。因此，里面有很多笑话。而且你拥有。对过去几十年喜剧的广泛调查。我非常努力地想要涵盖各种各样的人、喜剧类型、喜剧媒介，但即便如此，这仍然只是冰山一角，因为内容太多了。喜剧太庞大了。你在 TikTok 上看到的喜剧与你在单口喜剧、搞笑电影中看到的喜剧、你读到的喜剧非常相似。我用了劳伦斯·斯特恩的书《项狄传》中的一个例子，这是一本非常搞笑的书，但是
it's hundreds of years old. It's all in the same continuum. They're all part of the same craft. and the same art. And my hope is that you will then see a comedian or a TV show, and while you're watching it, you can buy into that illusion of, this is just happening in front of me. And it's really funny. These people are geniuses. But that afterwards, you can appreciate a lot of work went into that.
它已经有几百年历史了。它们都在同一个连续体中。它们都是同一门手艺和同一门艺术的一部分。我希望你看到一个喜剧演员或一个电视节目时，在你观看的同时，你可以沉浸在那种幻觉中：这正在我眼前发生。这真的很有趣。这些人是天才。但在此之后，你可以体会到其中倾注了大量的心血。
A lot of craft went into that. And now I have a greater appreciation for the people who did it. Because ultimately, we're people. We live in a world of people. All the jokes are for people. Animals don't laugh at jokes, particularly. Maybe smarter gorillas. But anything you're saying is in order to connect from one person to another person.
其中倾注了大量的手艺。现在我更加感激那些做出这一切的人。因为归根结底，我们是人。我们生活在一个人类的世界里。所有的笑话都是为了人。动物通常不会对笑话笑。也许更聪明的猩猩会。但你所说的任何话，都是为了从一个人连接到另一个人。
And so to be able to, for a moment, share a thought or a feeling with another human being and to have that moment of risk where you're not sure if they're going to connect with you. And then they don't. And you can be like, oh, that didn't work. Or they do. And you go, this is amazing. Like, that's the whole reason to create art. And it's certainly the reason that I create comedy.
因此，能够有一刻与另一个人分享一个想法或一种感觉，并拥有那个充满不确定性的时刻，你不确定他们是否会与你产生共鸣。然后他们没有。你可以觉得，哦，这行不通。或者他们有。然后你会觉得，这太棒了。这，就是创作艺术的全部原因，也绝对是我创作喜剧的原因。
Elliot, this has been fantastic. Thanks for coming on the show. Thank you, Roman. I really appreciate it. Thanks for having me. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg and edited by Delaney Hall, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Elliot Kalin's book is called Joke Farming, How to Write Comedy, and Other Nonsense.
埃利奥特，这次访谈太棒了。谢谢你来到节目。谢谢你，罗曼。我真的很感激。谢谢你邀请我。本周的《99%无形》由乔·罗森伯格制作，德兰妮·霍尔编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯万·里尔提供。埃利奥特·卡林的书名为《笑话耕作：如何创作喜剧及其他废话》。
It is fantastic. It is laugh-out-loud funny. You will learn a lot from it, even if you're not a comedy writer. What will link on our website, and you can find it wherever books are sold. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, the rest of the team, including It's Chris Brubay, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashma Don, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon, and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
这本书太棒了。它让人捧腹大笑。即使你不是喜剧作家，也能从中学到很多东西。我们会在网站上提供链接，你可以在任何出售书籍的地方找到它。凯茜 2 是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，团队的其他成员，包括克里斯·布鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·雷、拉什玛·唐、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特雷德利，还有我，罗曼·马斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
We are part of the Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是天狼星XM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部位于向北六个街区的潘多拉大厦。位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上有一个指向该链接以及 99PI 过去每一集的链接。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。